also opting out yesterday giants left
tackle nate solder a big money free
agent acquisition who came from the
patriots a couple of years ago there had
been some speculation that he would opt
out due to his own personal health
issues and family health issues there
had been reports he wouldn't opt out he
makes the decision yesterday to stand
down it's nine million dollars in salary
that he will forego this year he got a
three million dollar roster bonus back
in march and the way it works is you
keep that right but everything under
your contract gets pushed back by a full
year so march of 2021 when he was due to
make a 4 million roster bonus that that
money doesn't come due his career gets
put on hold for a full year next year if
he's on the team he gets the 9 million
base salary and then in march of 2022
he'd be eligible for that four million
dollar roster bonus so he's putting his
career on hold for a year and it has to
make the giants chris feel better about
using the fourth overall pick in the
2020 draft on andrew thomas who was
already in the process of kind of
potentially depending upon how he works
out supplanting nate's solder as the
left tackle but you know we know how it
works on offensive lines you need five
guys who can play right and we see guys
get moved around all the time hey we're
moving you from the left side to the
right side because we'd rather have two
good tackles
than two good left tackles because we
need to have two good tackles because
you can have the best left tackle in the
history of football if the other four
guys stink your quarterback's still
getting killed yeah that's right you
know i mean if khalil mack lines up on
the other guys on the other side yeah
it's great that you get a great left
tackle the right tackle stinks he's
going to get a sack it doesn't matter so
uh i mean th this this is a
you know this is a blow to the giants
certainly i mean first off nate soldier
you know it's easy he's made a lot of
money in his career right it's a little
different than damien williams he's made
some big money and of course got that
three million dollars already this year
so that makes that decision easy now
he's at a part of his career too where i
would go ooh i don't know where it goes
from here you know i don't think he's
going to be collecting big checks you
know there's a part of me that thinks
hey maybe the giants you know with the
way nate soldiers played and listen dave
gettleman i think this was way too much
money he paid no mate soldier and free
agency a few years ago i thought that
was a little crazy but regardless he was
trying to make a
a statement to his team getting bigger
and more physical and all that so i
understand it but they got to be looking
at this a little bit going man nate
soldier hasn't played well we got a
franchise left tackle they signed cam
fleming in free agency he was in new
england at one point with joe judge and
all them so there is some they drafted
another tackle in the third round they
have some options here and you know for
nate solder i totally understand where
he's coming from and this this
standpoint between his own life and his
child and some of the the issues they've
had to go through uh i totally get it
here
daniel jones last year pressured on 41.7
percent of his drop backs according to
pro football focus second only to sam
darnold we've talked at length about the
daniel jones fumbling problems part of
it was the clock in his head wasn't
telling him get rid of the football
before he got hit and the ball came out
so issues the giants going to have to
deal with yeah without nate solder
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports